Fred rogers was a legitimate American national treasure over 31 seasons.
He proved to be the reliable compassion and always friendly neighbor who guided
millions of youngsters through that childhood.
Fred single handedly introduced children's educational television in the
process,
elevating a medium that was heading downhill.
Fost is radical.
Kindness typified by a gentle and personal manner helps bring sanity to a world
beset by problems having Mr Rogers as our neighbor made the world a safer place.
Frederick mcfeely Rogers entered the welds on March the 28th,
19,
28 at his grandparent's house in Latrobe,
Pennsylvania.
His parents,
James and Nancy were extremely pious people.
So young.
Fred grew up in a very religious household.
James Works at the mcfeely brick company,
which was owned by his father.
He was a hard working industrious men who taught these traits to his son.
Nancy volunteered at the local hospital as a nurse's aide.
She had a deep love for helping others,
which also was a huge influence on fret.
In later years,
Fred would fondly remember how his mother required everyone in the family to
hand knit sweaters every Christmas for the troops during the war years.
This family ritual instilled in fresh I love for sweaters,
and they became his trademark during his TV show Mr Rogers neighborhood in years
to come.
Every one of the hundreds of sweaters he wore on the show was [inaudible] by
Nancy.
The extended Roger's family was very close with fred developing a special bond
with his grandfather.
The two spent many hours together where the old man would encourage friends to
be himself expressing all of his feelings and emotions freely.
This had a great impacts on Fred who fondly recalled how his grandpa had told
him that he made his day special by simply being himself.
Those words made fred feel special and he made it his mission in life to how
other people feel the same way.
When he was
11,
Fred's parents adopted a baby girl named Elaine.
Fred loved being an older brother even though elaine proved to be quite a
handful away from the love and the security of his family.
However,
Fred struggles,
he found it difficult to make friends,
often finding himself isolated and alone the other children made fun of the fact
that he was overweight and that he doesn't join in with that rough and tumble
play.
As a result,
he became rather quiet and shy.
His parents told him to ignore the negative feelings that were welling up inside
of him and focus on positive things.
This only made fred felt more heart and more confused in later years.
One of his key messages to parents was that children's feelings need to be
acknowledged rather than ignored.
The outlet that Fred stumbled upon two releases,
pent up emotions was the piano when he was just a few years old,
dense.
He would play the piano in order to sooth fret by five.
He was playing it himself.
He was a natural lands within a few years.
He was so proficient that he would play for guests and family members.
His acts would also include a puppet show.
Fred founds these outlets allowed him to express his feelings in a way that
wouldn't upset other people.
When he was 10,
Fred's grandmother bought in a piano of his own,
a $25 pump organ.
He spends hours each day practicing with his time and the keys being the only
periods that he felt like he was being his true self and his early teens.
Fred also became obsessed with photography,
developing his own brands in a basement darkroom.
His favorite thing to capture on film with the expressions on other people's
faces,
the Rogers family,
they attended the Presbyterian Church in Detroit.
From the very start,
Fred was eager and engaged.
He was entranced by every seven finding a personal connection to the message of
Christianity and the personality of Jesus Christ.
It inspired in him the deep felt desire to serve and help other people.
One Fred entered high school.
He was just a shy and unsessioned around his peers.
Whenever he did,
however,
develop a very unlikely friendship.
Friends,
it could never have imagined that he would become close friends with someone
like Jim.
Standout.
Standout was the popular and talented athletes and a football player when Jim
suffered a football injury.
However,
he was confined to a hospital bed for a period of weeks.
The school assigned Fred to deliver Jim's homework to him in hospital,
as well as making notes for him in class,
gym and Fred spent time together.
Friends came to appreciate each other.
Fred could see through Jim's exterior images,
the sports hank and Jim could appreciate Fred's quiet,
thoughtful nature.
When Jim was released from the hospital,
the friendship continued through Jim's influence.
The other students came to realize that Fred wasn't so bad after all,
Fred's hadn't changed,
but now the other students that's Mba himself without harassing him from this,
he learns a powerful lesson that he strived to impart to millions of children
through his TV show decades later.
The yourself without shame.
As a result of his new found acceptance by his peers,
Fred's confidence grew in leaps and bounds.
He became involved in school activities,
becoming editor of the school yearbook and the newspaper.
By the end of his senior year,
he was president of the student council.
He came to the respected rather than marks for his quiet,
thoughtful nature.
During his high school years.
Fred develops another relationship that was pivotal in his life.
George Allen was an African American friend of the family,
as well as sharing Fred's passion for music.
Georgia was also a passionate pilots.
He shares his enthusiasm with threads,
teaching him to fly.
While Fred never developed George's passion for flying,
he was in tranced by Fred's love of imparting his aeronautical knowledge.
It was then that he learns what it was to be a true teacher.
Upon graduating from high school,
it was Fred's intention to go to seminary and become a minister.
This seems to be his natural calling,
allowing him to serve others just as his parents had grieved him.
Still,
he felt a need to achieve a college degree and his love of learning inspired him
to enroll at Dartmouth College for his freshman year.
He decided to study the romance languages.
After a year,
however,
he decided that what he really wanted to study with music,
Dartmouth had no program,
was worthy of Fred's talents.
So he transferred to rollins college.
It was during an initial tour of the college that Fred ran into his future wife,
Sandra,
Joanne,
but Sarah became hugely impressed with Fred's piano playing ability and he
quickly became a part of his circle of friends.
Fred majored in music composition and minored in French language.
Prior to graduation in the summer of 1951,
Fred returned home on vacation.
He's still fully intended to attend a theological seminary after graduation,
but everything changed when Fred saw his first television show on the small
screen,
Fred watched is two men,
three pies into each other's faces.
In an instance,
he saw the potential in this new medium to educate millions of people once at
the same time.
He was appalled at the low brow way that television was currently being used.
Fred was so passionate about his desire to change the way that television was
being used,
that he decided on the spot to give up on his ideas,
to join the seminary and pursue a career in television.
Upon graduating from rollins with this music degree in hands,
Fred applied to NBC television in New York and asked if they had any positions
available.
He was hot by a producer named Charles Polo.
Check.
Fred moved to New York full of enthusiasm only to find that his days were spent
running errands.
He experienced the west and his colleagues,
especially those in positions of power.
In later years.
Fred remembered how one boss severely chastised him in public for forgetting to
put sweetener and his coffee.
He tried mostly in vain to bring a positive vibe to the office.
Fred's favorite NBC show was opera theater.
The show collaborated with famous composers to put on operas that were shown
across the nation via the tube.
Fred worked his way up to becoming a floor manager on the show.
He was in charge of timing the programs,
making sure the cameras are ready and letting the actors and know when to stop
and went to start.
His attentive personality allows them to shine in this role for it.
Also became floor manager on a handful of other shows.
He came to appreciate the wide variety of uses that television could be put to.
One of the shows he worked on was the Gabby Hayes show.
He watched and absorbed the lesson is hae spoken to the camera as if there was
only one person on the other side of the screen.
Ultimately though Fred became frustrated,
NBC wasn't showing any interest in moving into the use of television as a medium
of education,
he decided to leave and pursue his passion to bring music and education to the
masses,
especially children.
In 1953,
Fred and Sarah,
who had married the previous June,
heard of a new television station that was opening in Pennsylvania.
It was to be called Wq ed.
They decided that French should apply and he was offered a job as a program
manager.
Wq Ed was the first community television station in the United States.
Fred saw it as the ideal opportunity to shape educational content.
A month before w qbd was scheduled to go live,
the owners decided that a children's program would be a valuable addition to the
lineup.
Fred's and the young woman named Tracy carry the stations.
Secretary were tasked with coming up with something.
The they came up with was called the children's corner.
The children's corner started out very simply while Fred worked behind the
scenes,
JC introduced free children's educational films.
On the night before the show,
ad station director,
Dorothy Daniel gave fred a small tiger purpose.
As a good luck charm,
fred quickly dubbed this puppet is Daniel without telling anybody,
Fred positioned himself behind the backdrop,
which was simply a painted sheet.
As JC began introducing the first episode live on the air,
he cut a slit in the sheets and Danielle appeared on screen and it's began
conversing with JC.
The bobbitt proved to be a hit with audiences and puppets became a regular
feature of the show on this shape.
Fred's.
He was obviously the puppeteer as well as the organ player in order to rush
between the cells and the organ he took to wearing his trademark white tennis
shoes.
The children's going.
It became so successful,
but fred and JC became local personalities.
The show even came to the attention of NBC Fred's former employer when they're
head of religious programming.
When's on a four week vacation and BBC invited Fred and JC to fly to New York to
appear live.
Every Saturday morning.
They returned to Pittsburgh for the Monday morning show,
the NDC Saturday show now exposed fred to a national audience.
He began receiving hundreds of thousands of fan letters.
The NBC executives quickly secured Fred and Josee as regulars.
They also had larger,
more professional puppets made NBC put pressure on Fred and JC to quit w qed and
go daily on that channel,
but the power would not relinquish their loyalty to the original channel and
they continue to travel back and forth.
Despite his grueling TV schedule,
Fred continued to pursue his dream of achieving a theological degree.
He attended the Pittsburgh theological seminary and studied in the late hours
finally achieving his masters in divinity.
The most influential course he took was a masters counseling course during when
she worked with children to see how they reacted to puppet interactions.
He found that children reacted very differently with puppets than they would
with real people and would more easily open up and communicate with a puppet.
Fred was ordained in 1962.
His vocation was to work with children and families through the mass media.
Specifically,
television plans were put in action for a Fred's hosted show for the
Presbyterian church,
but before he got off the grounds,
Fred received the call that would change his life.
The cool came from Fred Rainsboro,
who was in charge of children's programming in Canada.
He wanted Fred to come to Canada,
earns,
puts on a 15 minute daily show,
specifically aimed at children and using puppets as well as his musical talents.
It was a huge risk,
Fred and Sarah,
who now had two young children,
but it was everything that Fred had been working towards and so they bit the
bullet and moved to Toronto,
but when he arrived,
Fred was shocked to realize that Rainsboro wants them to appear in front of the
camera rather than behind the scenes.
Rainsboro had seen Fred work one on one with children and knew that he had a
special gift to connect with them.
Over the next 12 months.
The two Fred's develops the programs concept with Rogers finally agreeing to
appear on screen.
The show was to be called Mr Rogers is one word.
Rainsboro felt that this would make it less formal to children.
The show was set up in a neighborhood with whimsical sets and puppets for Fred
to interact with and then named.
Ernie was brought in as the Babbitt here.
The show was a huge success in Canada.
However,
after the initial 12 month contract was up for Ed,
decided to move his family back to the United States to be closer to family,
but even that Pittsburgh Frederick waited patiently until Wq ed had room in
their schedule for another children's educational program.
After two years during which he held an education job with the church,
the funding came through for Fred to host his own show on w qed,
Mister Rogers' neighborhood.
The show premieres in October of 1966 for the first year.
It was essentially a rehashing of the Canadian version of Mr Rogers within 12
months.
However,
the format had expanded and the show had been picked up by the sears company as
a major sponsor,
enabling it to go to a national audience.
Frederick wrote the theme song,
which was to become famous.
Won't you be my neighbor?
The revamped show added more characters,
puppets,
and places to visit each episode.
Fred would go out of the studio and visit a new place.
The second national series in 1969 rolled out in full color in the third season.
The show which had become hugely popular,
was taken over by the Public Broadcasting Service or PDS.
The first round of Mr Rogers neighborhood continue to production for a total of
eight seasons and 455 episodes.
By then Fred's.
He was ready to take a break and so the show transitioned to reruns,
but Fred's.
We're still busy ever.
The perfectionist,
he took the opportunity to fix things that he didn't like from older episodes.
New original seasons of Mr Rogers neighborhood began filming in 1979.
Between then and 1990 3:15 new episodes were produced per season which shows
linking together and carrying through one overall theme for the entire season.
The huge popularity over the show was due to Fred's casual,
inviting and empathetic nature.
He never acted,
always striving to be genuine and honest.
His main method of teaching was through his own example.
As many of as audience members grew up with him,
the show would starts with Fred's talking directly to his child audience about
the subjects.
Then it would transition to a field trip which had been filmed earlier.
Then it would be back live where Fred would move into the neighborhood of make
believe this was a whimsical place where the characters could learn,
explore them,
and to act out specific scenarios.
Then Fred would move out of the neighborhood of make believe and discuss what
had happened in the neighborhood that day from start to finish.
The emphasis of the show was on communication,
opening up to others and exploring feelings.
Fred was not afraid to discuss any topic that was relevant to children,
including divorce and death.
In addition to these heavy topics,
Fred also encouraged children to have fun exploring the world around them and
keeping that curiosity alive in 2001.
Fred retired at the age of 71 after 31 seasons and 865 episodes.
If Mr Rogers neighborhood,
the show was officially over,
but Mr Rogers was still a familiar tv because of reruns.
Yes.
Who was best known for his landmark TV show,
Fred Rogers invested his time and energy into other work as well.
He was involved in the Children's book business,
held seminars for parents and produced many documentary style features.
The most well known of these was a series called Mr Rogers,
heroes and old friends,
new friends for the show.
Fred's traveled all over the United States talking to admirable people.
Fred authored a total of 36 children's books dealing with issues ranging from
fear of going to the hospital to potty training.
Fred's passion for children's education led to his involvement in advocacy work
in 1979.
He founded a nonprofit organization called Family Communications,
Inc.
He also made his voice heard on the national level when he became involved in
government issues.
In 1969,
He appealed to a group of senators in an effort to stop the federal government's
cutting funding to pbs.
Largely as a result of his efforts,
the funding was actually increased by $10,000,000 in 1984.
He was called as an expert witness in a case between sony and the universal city
studio.
The case was about the new sony technology called beta max,
which was the forerunner of the video recorder.
This new technology threatens hollywood's and universal brought the case to stop
sony on the grounds of copyrights.
Fred testified on behalf of sony stating the importance of parents and children
being able to tape his show for viewing later.
Sony ultimately won the case
a year after his retirement from television.
Fred was diagnosed with stomach cancer.
His last public appearance was when he tossed the coin at the 2003 rose bowl.
A few weeks later,
he underwent surgery to get rid of the cancer.
It was unsuccessful and fred when time to spend his last weeks with his family,
he died on february the 27th,
2003 surrounded by his family and his devoted wife,
sarah fred's passing was warned around the world,
but it was felt the hardest and his native pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
His memorial was held there and it was attended by thousands of people,
including many celebrities.
Pbs took steps to help children to come to terms with the loss of Mr. Rogers.
They continue to our reruns and a special insight,
or fred rogers,
america's favorite neighbor,
was hosted by michael keaton during his lifetime.
Fred receIved many awards including the presidential medal of freedom in 1999.
He was inaugurated into the television hall of fame and one of his sweaters was
featured in the smithsonian institute as a treasure of american history.
The greatest legacy of fred rogers is the show that made him a national
treasure.
The lessons he imparted of tolerance,
compassion,
love,
and empathy are just as relevant today as they were when Mr. Rogersrogers'
neighborhood first went to add in the 19 sixties.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every monday and every thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button.
That'll send you a notification every time,
every monday and thursday when we put out a new video.
also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the rice and as always,
thank you for watching.